tiene 23 años quedó embarazada en mayo y
se suponía que iba a abortar el día que
la Corte Suprema de los Estados Unidos
derrogó El fallo Rover versus wade
mi amiga me iba a llevar ella se
presentó en mi casa teníamos todas mis
cosas listas y Recibí una notificación
en mi teléfono de las noticias de ap que
decían que Row había sido anulado
inmediatamente después de eso recibió
una llamada de planificación familiar y
me dijeron que no podían verme que
efectivamente el aborto en Wisconsin era
inmediatamente ilegal estaba molesta por
el impacto que tuvo en el país pero
también por el impacto que tuvo en mí
como individuo
trabajando por las tardes como camarera
para pagar sus estudios White dice que
no habría podido criar a un hijo sola a
pesar de sus dificultades pudo llegar a
la vecina Minnesota a tiempo para
abortar
fue muy difícil para mí pero al mismo
tiempo soy un estudiante Universitaria
tengo Educación tengo un trabajo tengo
un automóvil sigo siendo una
privilegiada
fue una situación horrible pero no podía
imaginar pasar por ella sin algunos de
esos privilegios diría que de todos los
problemas que enfrenta nuestro país para
mi personalmente los derechos de las
mujeres son el número uno según una ley
Estatal de 1849 que actualmente está
siendo impugnada en los tribunales es un
delito grave realizar un aborto excepto
cuando la vida de la madre está en
riesgo sin excepciones por violación o
incesto un retroceso de los derechos de
las mujeres que ha impulsado los
activistas antes de las elecciones de
medio término del 8 de noviembre
Hola Laura soy Yola trabajo con Planet
parenthoods Wisconsin Así que hoy
estamos hablando con los vecinos para
ver cómo se siente la gente después de
la reciente decisión de la Corte Suprema
que anuló Rose versus wade hay algunos
caminos para restaurar los servicios de
aborto legal en Wisconsin
tengo miedo pero me da Esperanza saber
qué gente dispuesta a luchar por lo que
todos merecemos plan Hood tenía como
objetivo gastar un récord de 50 millones
de dólares para elegir a Los partidarios
del derecho al aborto en todo el país
hay políticos a los que les gustaría
codificar el derecho al aborto que
realmente se mantenga como ley nacional
en el Estado de Wisconsin por lo tanto
desde nuestro punto de vista es
importante que elijamos líderes que
defiendan los derechos reproductivos que
luchen para restaurar este acceso y
hagan lo que puedan a nivel legislativo
y judicial para restaurar el acceso a
esta atención médica esencial una ola de
registro de mujeres hizo que las nuevas
votantes femeninas en Wisconsin
superarán en número a los hombres por 17
puntos y los demócratas depositaron sus
esperanzas de nacer del aborto el tema
central de las elecciones intermedias